thank you for attending the sessions for
the track towards human life visual
learning and reasoning
thanks also to our speakers for giving
these inspiring and insightful talks
our sessions provide broad courage of
visual computing and learning
as our speakers highlighted integrating
human prior knowledge into deep learning
is fundamental to the future of machine
learning
we can leverage information and
knowledge from other modalities such as
language and speech to enhance
generalization of ai models
adapting to the real world scenarios for
example by applying fusion learning for
unseen downstream tasks can help us
focus on the real research problems
rather than pursue higher realms on
public datasets
it's also interesting to integrate deep
neural networks from the perspective of
information theory
which can
changing behaviors and be applied to the
design of neural networks
in looking ahead to the future of
computer vision research for certain
will continue to unlock the potential of
computer vision for real-world scenarios
we are all incredibly enthusiastic about
building a better future
we will already advance the
communication research and shape the
evolution of ai fundamentals and i
believe this trend will continue
microsoft research is committed to
investing in this research area we plan
to apply the latest advances in computer
vision to improve our products
we look forward to collaborating with
you the experts in academia and industry
to further accelerate basic and applied
research in computer vision
please check out our computer vision
research go to microsoft.com
research and search for computer vision
where you'll be able to watch webinars
on the various applications of computer
vision and read publication on the
latest research
you can also view the multiple career
opportunities we have here at microsoft
research
thanks again for joining us the 2021
microsoft research summit we hope to see
you again at another microsoft research
event soon